Hello Freak bitches.
You know I think about that last year I
did blow.
I was ready to call 60 minutes.
Okay.
Think of this state of mind right now,
like I had already a pitch for 60
minutes to explain to them that I had
found the cure for cocaine.
If you do heroin on Mondays just a
little bit,
you will not snort the rest of the week.
Like I was really going to pit 60
minutes.
I was going to get an agent and go to
CBS and the list.
I got a groundbreaking idea.
There's no reason for rehabs.
We'll get that white powder you
motherfuckers are going to war for
and we'll get that little white poppy
seed will make it into some pill and
we'll get people high on Monday because
the rest of the week I didn't want to
get high.
How crazy is that?
I was doing heroin on a Monday and it
wouldn't let me do the rest of the week.
I look forward to Mondays.
Fox,
CSI Miami.
Why only Monday?
I Dunno,
I dunno,
I have no fucking idea.
That was just a week off,
right?
That was just snorting it.
Yeah.
Snort at two little lines of heroin just
to get me out.
And what does it do?
Like what's the feeling?
Hit.
Tell me what it feels like when it hits
you.
Oh,
it takes a couple minutes to hit and you
feel this weird thing and then you feel
like your blood pressure going up and
you feel like this euphoric warmth.
You feel like this fucking to.
I felt like my body.
Did you ever take a white shit?
It's warmer.
You can see if you shit outside.
Steve's gonna come out of it.
That's what your body feels like that
one and then I would get an urge to puke
for a couple minutes.
I would gag and Puke a little bit,
would come out of yellow and then after
I put a little bit,
I would just go into this state of
fucking bonus for four hours.
It was like smoking in their cars all
day and mum onus,
like just sitting there smoking a
cigarette,
looking out a window,
and I'd make believe I was writing John
Lennon type lyrics to until I looked at
them the next day.
This brilliance about a refrigerator.
Like I remember writing a bit about a
refrigerator once and looking at it the
next day and say,
thank God,
thank God I never tried.
You know what I'm saying?
Like little things like just,
well that was hedbergs drug of choice
and his jokes,
man,
it's,
I think he's probably the best
nonsequitor joke I ever because all his
jokes are unrelated.
It's like here's a nonsequitor.
Here's some other things I was thinking
about.
Here's something I thought his,
um,
I saw and it was like,
I was listening to it the other day is
like,
half of his jokes were only funny
because he was saying them,
you know,
but they were hilarious.
Like he had a,
he had a way of doing it that was Kinda
like heroin comedy,
you know?
Would they be messed up during the week
or no?
Who?
Uh,
it takes me a day to recover on Tuesdays
I'd be out.
I didn't say nothing to nobody.
I was doing the and I wasn't doing cold
showers.
Really Fun.
So you would be like sober Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and then he'd look forward to the big
bump on Monday?
Yeah.
The kids that used to send it to me,
he used to send me $7 bags.
What kid?
His name was a bonehead.
He died from an old date.
How weird.
Yeah.
Fairy that counts to live forever.
I knew I knew bonehead from my
restaurant piece.
Last phone had Bergman taste about bone
health.
Bone health was like your boy.
He was.
I could go into a room with 90
motherfuckers in bone that will
liquidate of them.
Bonehead was a bad motherfucker dog.
I love bump on her three brothers.
I love Dalton,
but bone that was in two of the brothers
were very successful and bleeding bone
head was successful as a plumber.
He had his own company.
He only went crazy at night bone.
That bone head when I was 17,
would take me to mcsorley's hell house
in New York City Id.
He called the bartender.
I'm going to give them three mugs of
beer,
given three mugs or beer and give him a
bowl of Chili.
Mug would take 10 bucks for the both of
us and he'd go to Washington Square Park
and he come back and he gave me eight
volumes and by the meantime he would go
by his heroin and they buy these mixture
of pills and they melt them to the black
and whites.
They take us to a strip club in New
Jersey or something and they take us
home and the next day,
seven in the morning,
that strip had this bone head in the
fucking in the fucking a plumbing van up
and Dan that he was a functioning
addict.
He wasn't like your regular.
There's a lot of those guys out there
and he had a check that was a 13 bailey.
She was half Asian,
half Irish,
and they used to do heroin together and
they'd pass out in the living room late
fucking.
They both go to sleep and then I'd be in
the bedroom because I just moved in with
bonus.
They were Italian.
They were real fucking the talents and
the mother used to.
The mother was the first person ever
made me an eight grade.
She was a little Irish chicken and she
said that she used to say the word Earl.
She couldn't say oil and she was the
bookkeeper for union 52,
whatever.
The teamsters,
the Labor unit.
I was over there one day when I was 16.
She goes,
you've got a book,
walk me to work tomorrow.
Get your book.
You can start fucking being it.
So I,
you know,
like a hod carrier,
like hod carrier for the brick masons.
She goes,
I can get you with the Italians or by
the brick mason.
She was from hoboken,
so she got me a book.
I financed that.
She got a loan shark to finance it.
I love these people.
This is,
if I'm thinking it might be,
I don't like doing documentaries,
but I need to do a documentary about
this family because it's the rise and
fall of American family.
I saw before my eyes as a child that
went over there and ate with them and
hanging out with all three brothers by
the like I wasn't just friends or
bonehead with Chrissy fish and I hung
out with the little whatever his name
was,
but bone hood was my nighttime guy.
Bonehead used to take me into the murky
waters of the underworld.
He can get me guns and shit.
Another medium brother was a drug dealer
in the eighties and he drugged he so big
times coke and he used to buy jewelry
and he used to put them in a tackle box.
So one night me and the younger brother
in the bed,
sleep and bone had comes in the borrow
money from us because he was going to
the city again,
heroin.
And he goes,
he and I got it.
I got to go to the back.
I don't have any money on me.
He went into his brother's room and
instead of his brother was sleeping,
the drug dealer,
instead of just opening up the tackle
box and taken $40 out,
he took the whole tackle box and it had
$40,000
cash and was 30 and jewelry.
He went to the Bronx.
These are the best times in my life by
comrade is your war stories and you saw
that house was haunted and this was not
a hunter,
so the house at all these people were
decent Italian people.
Dad was a longshoreman and the mom was
in charge of the teamsters union and
they hung out with westies.
They hung out with the fucking.
The mother was friends with this dude
that was a a whatever for the West East
and he used to get me jobs.
He would get me jobs,
casing joints.
When you have a summer job now,
he would tell me,
come in,
I want you to go that warehouse.
I'm going to give you $200.
They're going to give you one 80.
I want you to go in that warehouse and
write down all the alarms and tell me
where the safe is.
Walks around the safe and he would pay
me money.
This was a great house.
Stop old school Italian announcement
back the bonehead bone.
It has the fishing tackle box.
He's about to go upstairs to buy heroin
and shoot it.
He puts the tackle box and the garbage
can in front of the building and puts a
lid on it.
When he's upstairs shooting heroin,
the garbage bin come and they take the
40 large with the $30,000
fucking jewelry to understand me.
I mean this was nonstop.
Le Bonheur came home high on heroin.
He decided to make French fries,
so he put the pot out,
but that this.
Remember in the eighties they had those
pots.
You could bring it home with the hot oil
and they would boil and you could throw
French fries.
America went crazy over him.
I forgot what they were praised
everybody.
Everybody was making onion rings and
shit.
Well,
he did heroin and knotted up and left.
That thing went on fire.
Of course,
we're all on the fucking house.
Oh Jesus.
All right.
I went into oil.
I wake up,
boom and alarms and awesome coach waking
me up and we'll go out of the house and
the is outside.
The grandmother and the fire department
crawls on top of the roof.
Joe,
when they hit the fucking roof to let
the smoke out and fire trucks are coming
from the side land water and they got
the sirens in the middle of all this had
taken them on and we all look around and
go,
oh my God,
Emile stonehouse,
bonehead was still in the house on fire,
Bro.
They turn the fire off.
They go in and he's still with his feet
up with his.
Just heroin out of his mind.
He slept through the fire.
Oh my God.
Everything.
When they woke up on my fries,
ready?
Crazy.
This family was ready.
We have to fucking battalions after nine
slash 11 hours.
Are you still fucking sleeping?
Oh my God.
It burned the house down.
Burn the fucking kitchen down and half
the bedroom.
They had a movie for a hotel for six
months and they had a grandmother
downstairs.
It was old school Italian,
but you couldn't smell,
so we kinda,
we smoked pot.
We just got on there and blow smoke in
his face and grandma would pass out in
the wheelchair and that was the end
that.
I mean it didn't stop.
It didn't stop genius.
So this is why you get mad at people for
binge watching stuff on Netflix and this
is what you were talking about.
I get mad at everything are you got to
bother me for.
I get mad when people like he used to
hide the coat.
The medium brother.
He used to hide the coke on his car and
I'd be walking down the hill and I could
see a little container that he didn't
even have a Maserati.
What's the other Italian call is how
much of a guineas?
These motherfuckers.
What?
What's the other Italian car like you
said?
The avanti Avanti.
Oh,
okay.
I remember those.
Remember that piece of Shit?
That was a piece of shit.
Pieces of shit.
Can you show me a piece of carbon trust?
Anything Italian?
Oh my God.
That was the.
He tried to sell it to me once.
It was through grants.
Yeah.
I drove it down the corner blows up.